In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to
your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will, that you never
perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all
the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the
Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are
in these writings and prayers. Amen. So we want to begin tonight with November the 9th, 1925,
and the Lord is speaking about fusing. So Louisa said, I was fusing myself in the holy divine
volition, according to my usual way, to then do my adoration to the crucified. So you fuse yourself
first and then do whatever prayer you're doing in the divine will, which we have done at the rose
rate tonight. And since more than once, while doing my acts in the supreme volition, I had been caught
by sleep, which had never happened before. I had not completed the first thing, nor done the adoration,
so I said to myself, first I will do the adoration, and then if I'm not caught by sleep, I will fuse
myself in the divine will. Now the Lord is letting her slip here for the sake of teaching you and me
what the divine order actually is. So while I was thinking about this, she didn't have to say
anything. My sweet Jesus came out from within my interior that that is Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians
3 16, the kingdom of goddess within you. So he placed his face close to mine and he told me. So this
is a very intimate thing, he's telling her, my daughter, I want you to fuse yourself in my divine
will first. So there's your instruction for all your new classes. You must come before the supreme
majesty to reorder all human wills in the will of their creator. Second, to repair with my own will
for all the acts of the wills of creatures that are opposed to mine. A third, my will came out of
us in order to divinise the creature. And the rest of the sentence doesn't make sense. Okay,
because my book says and a capital W will do we want. That's not English, it's not a sentence,
it's not anything. So I think perhaps that what they were trying to say was that God wanted the
creatures to do God's will. Okay, but there shouldn't be a capital on that W. My will came out of us
in order to divinise the creature. So therefore if we're to be divinised, we're to be at that level
and carry out the will of God. And when this will, that's the divine will, is rejected by them
to do their own will, it is the most direct offence to the creator. Now it takes quite a lot of
instruction for us to come to realise that in very practical ways in our own everyday lives.
It is to deny all the goods of creation and to move away from his likeness. Now notice,
as we have moved into volume 18, the Lord is beginning to refer to the divine will and his
in the singular as well. So we're talking about God's will and he can refer to as his will.
So as they move away from the divine will, they also move away from the divine likeness as well.
Do you think that is just trivial? That fusing yourself in my will, you place the whole of this
will of mine as though on your lap, which though it is one brings its divinising act to each creature.
So here we have this enormous reality that fusing in the divine will means we are entering into
that divine will that's in everything and in everything and therefore we are touching everything
and everyone that's in that divine will. And even though the act of the divine will is one,
it brings its divinising act to each creature, just like the sun brings its light to every part of
the earth. And reuniting all these acts in my will together, you bring them before the supreme
majesty, one, to requite them with your will together with mine, two, to requite them with your love
because God is love. Redoing all the acts opposite of those of creatures and three, you press this
same will of mine to surprise the creatures once again with more repeated acts so that they may know
at the divine will and that they may be able to receive the divine will within themselves
as the prime act. Now the divine will is in us anyway, but to receive the divine will as the prime
mover or the prime act inside of us means that the divine will has taken over from the human will
and therefore we are living at this divine level that he actually wants us to live at and therefore
all the acts are at that level and have that extraordinary effect. So he wants us doing the
requiting in love and in reparation for everybody so that he can go to others and he can surprise
them with wonderful gifts to draw them into the divine will. So the adoration of my wounds more
than one does this for me. See the translation is terrible. What Jesus is saying, there's lots of
people who will do the stations of the cross or who will look at some aspect of the passion,
like devotion to the divine face or whatever. He says, but they're not they're not doing it
having fused in my will. So they're doing it at a lower level. So this is where Louisa had said
at the beginning of this that, well, okay, I'll do the adoration first and then I will fuse and
he said, no, no, no, no. You've got to fuse first so that you can be raised up to this higher level
and do it on the divine level. So he says, others can do this for me. But giving me back the rights
of my will as the prime act, which I did towards man, no one does this for me. He had to teach Louisa
to reveal this to us so that we could begin to do it. Therefore, it's your duty to do it.
And you, that is Louisa, have a special mission about my will. So he's revealing this specifically
to her. She has to pass it on to the rest of the church so that gradually we can pick it up
and begin to do it. And if sleep catches you while you are doing it, your celestial father will look
at you with love in seeing that you sleep in his arms. Now what he's saying is, if you have fused
yourself in the divine will, and then you fall back to sleep, as far as the heavenly father is
concerned, you're sleeping on his lap and you are still operating at the divine level. But if you go
asleep on your own level, then you won't reach that. So he says, no, you must fuse first. You must
fuse first. St. Therese of Lisieux had a problem of staying awake for early morning prayer because
Carmelites pray at an ungodly hour in the morning if you excuse my expression. And she was asked once,
you're not having a problem about sleeping during prayer when you should be giving your
adoration and praise to God. And she said, no, he doesn't stop being God. I think that's a fantastic
thing. And the image I would give you is an infant in its mother's arms. And the child has been fed
at the breast. So the child is happy and satisfied and falls right asleep in the mother's arms. Does
the mother cease to be a mother? Does she cease to do all the things that the child needs? The answer
is no. In fact, she takes more care because the child has now gone into this sleep state. So Jesus
is saying to Louisa, if you fuse in the divine will and then fall asleep, no problem because you're
falling asleep at the right level. So we need to be sure that our nights are in the divine will as
well as our days. And I will give you Sam one three one for that. My soul is like a weaned child on
its mother's lap. So if sleep catches you, Jesus said, while you're doing it, our celestial father
will look at you with love in seeing you asleep in his arms and seeing his little daughter who even
while sleeping holds on her laps, all the acts of the divine will. You see, once you fuse, you have
all the acts of the divine will there with you to repair them to requite them with love and to give
to each act of our will, the honor, the sovereignty and the right that be fits it. Therefore, first
fulfill your duty. This is divine advice. This is what if I was putting a note on the side of this
page here, I would write divine advice. First, fulfill your duty. And then if you can, you will
also do the adoration of my wounds. Now, what's your duty? Enter into the divine will fuse yourself
in the divine will reach out onto this higher plane where God can do incredible things.
So let's go on to November the 12th, 1925, talking about Louisa being called to a divine mission.
So Louisa obeys, I was fusing myself for the holy divine wish, according to my usual way,
and my sweet Jesus moving in my interior class may all to himself and placed himself in the act of
giving me a lesson and a correction. And he told me, my daughter, be attentive in doing your acts
in my will. See, the problem is that we get very used to saying things, and you may be very used
to making certain acts and so they'll rhyme off. He says, no, no, no, be very careful in doing acts
in my will. You must know that for one who is called to be the head of a mission now, it's even
more important in her case. The more he encloses of the good pertaining to that mission, the more
good he will be able to communicate to others. These goods will be like many seeds, which he will
lend to others so that whoever has the fortune of wanting to acquire those seeds may become the
possessor of the harvest of those seeds. He's saying to her, as he has said in earlier volumes, that each
act you do in the divine will is adding another thread, another thread, another thread to this
wonderful garment of the divine will acts, which is our participation in creation, redemption and
sanctification. But he says it's also creating seeds for future people. And so the more we do them,
the more he's going to use the term in very soon, the more divine currency we actually make,
so that we can exchange, if you like, for souls. So he's telling her that the more carefully she
does the acts and the more she repeats the acts, the more treasure she's leaving behind for the
generations coming after her. He said, and he gives an example then of Adam. This happened with
Adam, you know, being the first man, he was constituted the head of all generations. And being the head,
it was necessary for him to possess the seeds in order to give to others what is necessary for the
development of human life. So everything had to be placed in Adam, so it could be passed on to
future generations. So regardless of the fact that these seeds have been expanded and then there's
an extraordinary word, elucidated, which is not in the dictionary. Okay, let me use a much simpler
word, explained or elucidated. Once these have been expanded and explained, once they're known,
and then according to the goodwill of the following generations to the capacity and the application
that they have used over these very seeds. So once this stuff is there and it has been explained
and passed on to the next generations, then they can make use of these seeds. So even though it's
going to go down the generations, Jesus said, nevertheless, Adam had them all within himself.
Now he's continuously telling us that the sun has all the light and the sun passes on this light
to the earth. And no matter how much it passes on to the earth, it still has all the light.
So Adam has all of this within himself, even though he has to pass it on to the generations,
Louisa will have it all, even though she has to pass it on to the generations.
So nevertheless, Adam had them all within himself and it can be said that everything comes from him.
So of course, you know then we're going to be told that everything comes from Louisa since
she's the head of this mission. He was endowed with all sciences. Now the problem with the word
science and sometimes I replace it with the word knowledge is because the word science is quite
complicated today and it may not quite touch what Jesus is saying. He's saying all knowledge,
which includes the natural sciences that we have today. But for us today, the word science is
actually very specific and may not include the wisdom and understanding and everything that the
Lord intends. That's why I sometimes put the word knowledge instead. So he was endowed with all
sciences, with all knowledge. And so we're going to discover what this knowledge was,
what others learn with so many efforts, all our schooling and all the rest of it.
He possessed as a gift infused knowledge. And we have seen from the very beginning of these
writings that the Lord gave Louisa infused knowledge by this extraordinary science of mystical living
or we say mystical sciences. Okay, it's all infused. She didn't get it from books. So Adam had
everything infused. Why? He was the first. If it wasn't infused, he wouldn't have it. So he possessed
the knowledge of all things of the earth. He had the knowledge of all plants and all herbs and the
virtue that each of them contained. Now another word that's used continuously by the translators
is the word virtue. And they use it in all kinds of contexts. Most of the time I translate that
word virtue as power. Here it probably means the effects. So he had the knowledge of all
plants and all herbs and the effects that they would have on human beings. You see where I'm
getting the word effects. In other words, ancient peoples today who have not yet been destroyed by
modern life still know that the answer to all human illness is in plants. It's in herbs. I actually
had the privilege of living close to a clinic in West Africa where the man who ran the clinic
never charged his patients unless he cured them. And all he did was he went to the herbs of the
earth and to find out where was the solution. Okay. Somebody sent me a little chat there telling me
that I could use the word benefits, which is good. So thank you. Thank you for that. So all the
benefits you can get from all of these herbs. So Adam knew all of that by infused knowledge. He
didn't have to learn it from anybody. He had the science of all species of animals and how he could
use them. Now that statement is illustrated in the the most childlike way in the book of Genesis
where you're told that all the animals were lined up in front of Adam and that he named them.
And he decided, you know, which were different species and realized that the human race was a
completely different species. So you couldn't cross and marry these species that were all different.
And they all had different functions and everything. It's given to you in a very childlike way
in Genesis. So he knew all about all the species of animals and how to use them. He had the science
of music. Isn't that incredible? So I would dare you see, I'd want to put the word knowledge.
He had the knowledge of music, singing, of writing. Isn't that amazing? And of medicine.
Hence his knowledge of the plants. He had knowledge of everything. So when he lived in the fullness
of the divine will, he also lived in the fullness of knowledge and understanding. And when the
Prophet Isaiah gives us a list of the sevenfold gifts of the spirit that dwelled in the Messiah,
its wisdom, number one, understanding, counsel, fortitude, and then knowledge. Now notice that all
of these actually intertwine together. I'm going to resist the temptation of going into it because
otherwise I'll do none of this. But they're all actually intertwined. So when you're told that Adam
had the fullness of knowledge, all of these gifts are intertwining in him. And he just knows what to
do. I think that's fantastic. And so I want to give you the book of wisdom chapter seven
verses 15 to 21 there that actually speaks of all the different aspects of knowledge.
So if the generations possessed each one, its special science, Adam possessed them all.
You can see then how it is necessary that one who must be the head must enclose everything within
themselves. So what Jesus is saying to Louisa is, I have to give you all the knowledge or the science,
whatever word you want to use, about the divine will. And if you get it all, you'll be able to pass
it on to the generations. If you don't get it all, you can't be the head. And it's given to you
with infused knowledge just as it was given to Adam. Adam couldn't deserve it. You couldn't
deserve it. Whenever we're dealing with God, we can't deserve anything. It's given to us
free grasses. It's wonderful. In the next paragraph then, we're talking about Louisa and the divine
knowledge that's infused into her. So it's the same with you, my daughter. Since I have called you
to be the head of a special mission more than a new Adam, that's very powerful language because
the New Testament calls Jesus the second Adam. So because we're dealing with a completely new
stage in the development of spirituality and relationship with God and the
redoing of everything so that God can actually come and reign upon the earth. He says that it's
better than a new Adam. And here it's not about human sciences or human knowledge, but about the
science of sciences, which is my will, which is the science of all heaven. In other words,
I'm infusing into you the knowledge that all the dwellers of heaven have. It's the way they live
because it's time for the fulfillment of the Lord's prayer that the will of God would be done on
earth in the same way as it's done in heaven. So he has to give her this knowledge of how the
will of God is actually done in heaven and bring her step by step by step to the reality of this
so that she can pass on that invitation and knowledge to us.
I want you, Jesus said, to enclose within yourself all the seeds which my will contains. Now all
the seeds, that's all the pieces of knowledge, all the pieces of revelation about the divine will.
And the more act you do in it, the more knowledge you will acquire. That's very interesting. In other
words, the more you put this into practice, the more you grasp what is being done. And therefore,
everything is in the living of the divine will. The more act you do in it, the more knowledge you
acquire and the more rays of light that you will place on the sun of my will so that would
greater fullness of light, the divine will be able to diffuse more for the good of the generations.
Now when I was meditating on this, the thing that really struck me was the humility of God,
that he asks one of his own little creatures to actually cooperate with him in a massive work
that he wants to do. This kind of humility is really beyond us. It's incredible.
And I want you to do it in such a way that stirred by the fullness of light,
they will be able to know with greater clarity the good which my will contains. So the more
Louisa works this, if I can use that language, the more light will be shed on living in the divine
will. And the more light that's shed on it through Louisa, the more clarity there is for us and the
easier it is for us to pick it up. So we will get the clarity of what it means to live in the divine
will and the great good that we can have and have our lives enriched by it. And then of course he
goes back to talking about the sun as an example. It will be the same as with the sun, which though
it possesses such great fullness of light, it can easily take the whole earth as though in its power
warm it illuminated and fertilize it in such a way that all may know some more, some less,
the good that it does in bringing its light to all. But if the sun in the height of its sphere were
poor in light, the light which descends down below could not fully illuminate the earth. That's a
wonderful explanation of what he's just said because he's saying to Louisa, you need to work this divine
will in such a way that the light in you becomes greater and greater and greater and greater and
therefore for the people following you they're going to be able to see with greater clarity.
So here he's saying that if the light of the sun was poor, there's an awful lot you couldn't
accomplish on the earth. At the most if the sun was poor, some small portion of the earth you know
that rotates closer to the sun would get it. But if to the sun, which was to illuminate the
earth naturally, I gave such fullness of light for the good of all the generations, much more do I
want to fill the fullness of the light of the sun of my will. So there you have the sun, he keeps
on giving the sun as an illustration of what he's trying to say. So taking the divine will now as
the divine sun the more light that it sheds then the more the creatures on the earth can actually see
here and understand and therefore that they can actually participate. So his light
enlightens our darkness. Our darkness comes from worldliness and sin and just plain ordinary
humanity and the more we are illumined by studying, I think the big illumination is studying
this material line by line, word by word, leaving nothing out and going back over it and over it
and over it and to me there was grace in actually reading it even if you don't understand some
parts of it. And that means we're exposing ourselves to this light and we're allowing therefore the
infusion of this light to come into us. So we don't need to be people who have university education.
Louisa didn't have because the target is not the intellect, the target is your spirit,
it's your innermost being and once that is illumined then your like a child can take something globally
into itself we can do that spiritually as well. So I'm giving such fullness of light for the good
of all generations notice all the generations to come which are absolutely divine. Much more
do I want to fill the fullness of light of the sun of my will which must illumine souls,
it must warm souls. So it's the more you touch this material the more the soul is opened up
to realize that there is a wonderful future I can have that if I want to I can enter into this
I don't have to be somebody special I only have to want this badly enough to open up to the Lord
and let him purify me and let it actually happen. So this material has to illumine souls it has
to warm them it has to cast into them the fecundity of the seed of divine sanctity. Now he alone can
put divine sanctity into us just as I chose Adam as the head just as I chose a point in the heavens
in which to fix the center of the sun so that it could illuminate the earth so I've chosen you
Louisa to be the center of the sun of my will and the fullness of light must be so great that
all may be able to enjoy it now notice the all God is not a respecter of presence and this gift
is opened up to absolutely anybody anywhere any age any country anything so long as they're willing
to open up and let God reorder their lives back into the original pattern. So the fullness of this
light must be so great that all may be able to enjoy it all may be invested by this light and
each one make it its own now this is something that I've stressed to my classes from the very
beginning and that the Lord doesn't want each one of us to look like each other he wants this mystery
to work its way through your personality through your character through your experience of life
through your version of being a human being so that heaven can look down and say well there's my
Mary there's my John and you can see from the formation that Jesus gave the apostles that they
were very distinct from each other and he didn't ask Peter to be like John that would have spoiled
the story completely because you had to have Peter mysteries and you had to have John mysteries
and so the sheer variety that the Lord wants to produce in all of us I think is one of the wonders
it's like producing a fantastic tapestry and every single color and every single shape and
everything is all part of it and if one color is missing then the whole thing is spoiled so each
one of us is part of this this wonderful wonderful thing that God is doing Ephesians 210 where God's
work of art created in Christ Jesus and so I've underlined this variety all the time that we we
must not be copycats you know and don't be afraid to say your own prayers in the divine will and
don't be afraid that you mightn't say something clever or you mightn't put it together with all
the wonders that you can find in a book but it's coming from the depths of your being
and it's you and you say oh yeah that's for ancestry she never says it nicely you know
but she says it and so the variety is important and he wants each one of us to be our own
special authentic selves because he made you and he made you special and he made you different
and he gave you the call and he has a place for you exactly in this wonderful tapestry of glory
a work of art a work of light a work of love a work of glory that will glorify him forever
this this variety is is extremely important and that's why Jesus says to Louisa this is why
your complete acts in my will are actually needed as well as the knowledge that I keep
manifesting to you because the more he manifests to her the more she's able to go deeper and deeper
and deeper into it okay so in the next paragraph you can ask the question how many acts do you have
to do I have a little heading for myself on this paragraph and it's the history of the acts
it's the usual way of the eternal wisdom Jesus said to establish the acts of the creature in order
to give completion to the good which it wants to do in her who God knows exactly the number of acts
you and I are actually going to do between now and the time we see him we're completely free
but he knows how much you're going to actually do but he's talking about something bigger here
and so it happened for the coming of redemption that's the four thousand years that we celebrate
an advent for the coming of redemption so it happened for the coming of redemption of
of the eternal word upon the earth it took the course of four thousand years and during this time
all the acts which creatures were to do in order to dispose themselves to err in the great good of
redemption had been established so in heaven the whole economy of your redemption was worked out
exactly how much prayer input had to be put there to prepare the way was already established
okay as well as all the graces and the knowledge which is the supreme majesty
was to give in order to make known the same good which the descent of the word would bring
into their midst so while all the prayers and sacrifices and acts of the people of the old
testament were all being done at the same time God was revealing to them by infused knowledge
through the prophets who this redeemer was and all about them so they were getting the knowledge
and they were doing the acts at the same time just like ourselves in preparing for this new era
and so here come the patriarchs the holy fathers the prophets and all the good of the old testament
who with all their acts were to cover the way the staircase in order to reach the fulfillment
of the longed-for redemption okay so the staircase then reminds you of Jacob do you remember the
letter up to heaven with the angels of God ascending and descending carrying out God's economy for him
okay and the next paragraph covers a very important answer to questions that people have
asked over the years and that is when you pray for about other people's acts do you change them
into divine will act the answer is no an act is what it is at the moment it is done so if my act
is to take this pen and to move it somewhere and it's done simply as a human act it remains that
so we have to see what work we do in the divine will to cover other people's acts this is not
enough Jesus said as good and holy as their acts were there was the so very high wall of the original
sin oh the very language tells you there was this huge barrier and of course studying the old testament
you can see that the original sin cropped up with with problem after problem after problem
and all their falling into idolatry so there was the very high wall of original sin which
maintained the division between the human race and God so this is why a virgin was needed one
conceived without sin innocent and holy and enriched by God with all graces now in other words there
had to be one person who was our tainted nature solitary boast that she was outside of this arena
of sin therefore she was outside of this ability that she could be pulled down by Satan she made all
the good acts of the course of four thousand years as though they were her own so there she is embracing
all the acts of everybody from Adam down to herself she covered them notice the covering
she didn't change them she covered them with her innocence with her sanctity and her purity
in such a way that the divinity would see those acts through the acts of the innocence of the holy
creature so it's like as if you put this wonderful gold wrapping on this gift and you hand it to the
father and the father sees this wonderful gold wrapping and the love with which it is offered
and therefore there's more mercy given to the people you're praying for it's good to remember
this if you're praying for people she covered them with her innocence her sanctity her purity
in such a way that the divinity could see those acts through the acts of this innocent and holy
creature who not only embraced all the acts of the ancients but surpassed them because
she was doing them in the divine will and this is why she obtained the descent of the word upon
the earth so what Jesus is saying here is that she incorporated all that went before her and
at the level that she was at she won this incredible grace of covering them to make them more special
in the eyes of God to lift them up to a higher value and so with all that went before her
and her own divine will act she won and so louisa is asked to do the same thing
except that louisa has to go not only the four thousand years before christ but the two thousand
years after him as well she's got to pick up all the acts of the church it happened to all the good
acts of the ancients as to one who has much gold and silver but the image of the king which gives
the value of money to that precious metal is not impressed on it and this is very very interesting
because you'd have to say to yourself I mean there's nothing wrong with the acts of all these
saints they just weren't at the the high level so what was the difference and so Jesus gives the
simplest of all explanations you could possibly give that you can have a gold coin but it doesn't
have the stamp of the reigning monarch and therefore it can't be used as currency so it was all the
acts of all the ancients before our blessed mother all their acts put into her hands became divine
currency I think that's fantastic I think it's absolutely brilliant because now we know what to
do without every everything else put them into her hands as well so even though the coin contains
value in itself in other words these acts were not useless it cannot be called divine currency
my book says value for money divine currency is what he's got talking about however suppose that
the gold or silver were acquired by the king that is taken into our ladies hands and offered now as
divine acts even though you can't change the original one the king accepts it and therefore
he can impress his image upon them and here is the right of currency acquired by that gold in other
words it has been raised into divine currency and that's what the virgin did she changed all the good
acts of all the people who had gone before her into divine currency and added with all her own acts
that was enough for the coming of the redeemer and now you're going to hear you don't even have to
need me to read it that all the acts of the church from the very beginning have got to be put into
louise's hands to do the same thing as as blessed mother has done to open the way for the divine will
of course louise doesn't do anything without her blessed lady anyway so that's what the virgin did
she impressed her innocence her sanctity and the divine will which she possessed as a whole upon
them as a whole means that there was no part of her at any point from the instant of her conception
that wasn't completely given and sacrificed to the divine will she presented them them all together
to the divinity she took all these acts together and she obtained the long for redeemer so the virgin
completed all the acts which were needed notice she completed she did change them
you can complete them because if she changed them what was the point in them living
what was the point in them struggling what was the point in them overcoming themselves what was
the point in them trying to be virtuous and grow in virtue and holiness and there were great saints
in the Old Testament if someone could come along and just change them it would say that you had no
value it's very interesting what the lord does but this wasn't the end jesus said so that the
redeemer might have his field of action upon the earth and whoever wanted to might use those acts
as coins that is divine currency with which to purchase heaven for himself the imprint of innocence
that's the problem with the human race of sanctity problem number two and of the divine will problem
number three was needed and the imprint of the operating of the word himself was needed in order
to make man rise to heaven so our blessed mother was able to go this far and then the lord himself
had to literally raise us from the dead so that's Ezekiel 37 the raising of the the dry bones
the dry bones coming to life so the word himself was needed in order to make man rise to heaven
okay if that of the virgin was enough to make me descend into the midst of creatures in order
to make man rise my divine operating was needed it's a very interesting thing so to get the divine
word to descend you need all the work of our blessed mother but to get the human race to rise
from the dead that required jesus himself and so this is why i embraced all those acts and i made
them my own and i made up for all now i love that i made up for everything that's the secret so
everything has got to be put into him everything is through him with him and in him i accomplished
everything and for all i placed the divine imprint on all of those good acts from the first to the
last man who was to come upon the earth it wasn't just stopping at a particular point
jesus died for everyone and this imprint was made by me with on herd of pains with the shedding
of blood that means he redeemed everything every single sin every single fault everything
he didn't cover it he redeemed it and so like a magnanimous king i gave to all the coins with
which i gave to all sorry the currency with which to purchase heaven for themselves
all this had been established by the uncreated wisdom i love that expression on created wisdom
because in the old testament that was how they identified god the uncreated wisdom
and there are seven wisdom books and not even one act of all this could be missing in order
for redemption to take place what you notice in all of this description is the sheer detail
with which god deals with things and that every single part of the plan must be brought to perfection
nothing can be left out nothing at all now my daughter just as it was with redemption
so it will be with the divine will see you've you've seen him do this over and over and over again
he'll he'll explain things and he in order to explain something to a louisa he will go through
the mission that our blessed mother had and he himself had and then he'll come to her
so it will be with my will in order to make it known and to make it rain as the prime act of life
the prime mover in the creature the fulfillment of acts is needed so all of our acts in trying to
live the divine will are all essential for the whole pattern that the lord wants you too on the
example of our celestial mother and of mine must embrace in my will number one all the acts of the
old testament number two all the acts of our blessed mother the queen of heaven number three
all those done by myself which i've just been explained and number four all those which are done
are done and will be done by all the good and the saints up to the last day you've got to embrace
the whole thing if you're going to be the head of this mission and that this light and this grace
and this glory is to go out to everybody you must embrace all the acts done by in the old testament
those of our blessed mother those done by Jesus and all Christians and all the good people to the
very end and upon each one of them you are to place your seal of what a quite love love of blessing
and of adoration you're to do this with the sanctity and power of my will now we have no power but we
can do everything with the power and the sanctity of the divine will and so it's the most wonderful
thing that we can ask the lord to raise good acts into real sanctity through the sanctity of his
divine will we can make pure act more pure through the purity of the divine will and so on and so on
you can make loving acts much more loving divinely loving through the love that is the divine will
itself nothing must escape you my will embraces everything you too must embrace everything and
everyone and you must place my will alone at the first place of honor upon all the acts of creatures
now there's the adjustment into divine order because even the best acts of creatures can
have a tilt towards the self or a slight tilt or shadow from the world and so on and these acts
have all got to be reordered and that the entire direction of the act is towards the divine will
if you were to do this one by one it would be a very tall order
my will embraces everything and you too must embrace everything and everyone
and place my will alone in the first place of honor upon all the acts of creatures
it will be your imprint with which you will imprint the image of my will on all the acts of
creatures this is the beauty we have it's like as if you take a a stamp and you put this divine
stamp on something therefore your field is vast he's talking to louisa i want to see you in my will
flowing over all the graces and projities which i did in the old testament to give me your
requital of love and thanksgiving and in the acts of the patriarchs and the prophets to make up for
their love now louisa is being asked to do this much more than you and me you and i participate
in this mission but louisa is the head of this mission and therefore she has to do it completely
there's not one act in which i do not want to find you jesus said i would not be satisfied
or content if i did not find you in all the acts of creatures which have been done
and will be done in other words your participation in bringing the divine will into all acts past
present and future are actually necessary we have the extraordinary privilege of actually
putting our signature on creation redemption and sanctification it's amazing
i would not be content if i did not find you in all the acts of creatures which have been done
and will be done nor would you be able to say that you have completed everything in my will
you would lack something of the true living in the divine will i like that word the true living
in the divine that means that that you've you've entered into this completely but you've taken on
this divine will and letting yourself be drawn completely into it not partially
the true living in the divine will therefore be attentive if you want the fullness of light to be
enough to be able to illuminate all peoples with my will now the issue is having enough light
now you know from matthew of 5 17 that jesus said you're a lamp on a hill you must have enough
light to shine for absolutely everybody and here jesus is saying that louisa must have enough light
for all the people who are to live in the divine will in all the future generations
one who wants to give light to all must embrace all as though in one single embrace so there you
have the sun in its light embracing the whole earth you have the divine will in one act embracing
everything past present and future so you must do it as though in one embrace by making yourself
the life and the substitution of everything and everyone is my will perhaps not the life of everything
as john 14 6 i am the way the truth and the life is there not the need then for one
who would flow in everyone in order to sweeten this bitterness by substituting an act of life
with my own will for each act of the ungrateful creature now there's an enormous amount in what
we've just read absolutely ginormous and what i would say to each one of you is that you must take
this not just line by line but word by word and what i find useful at a thing like this is to
write down a list of what is actually being said so that i somehow can take on board the challenge
that is there now louisa was asked to do it in all its fullness as the head of the mission we're
asked to participate we don't have the same vocation as louisa and we're not sitting in a bed
24 hours a day you have a life to live you have a family to run you have a job to do you have
lots of things so the lord is asking you to participate but all of us together will make this wonderful
tapestry with the lord so i'm going to leave it there for tonight and we'll take up in november the
19th the next day and thank you for coming and God bless!